the year is just two months old already
catastrophe in argentina as a scorching
heat wave sparks raging wildfires
deadly landslides devastate brazil's
historic mountain town of petropolis
events like this together with ongoing
droughts floods and superstorms are the
new climate normal
and it's only going to get worse unless
something is done fast so says a
harrowing climate report that lays out
how civilization has accelerated the
decline of nature at the expense of
humanity and ecosystems
and that adaptation is urgently required
especially in the global south this is
about building our resilience being
prepared for worse things to come you
know how can we stop
uh and limit the impacts of climate
change that you know are happening now
and will happen further in the future
and so investment in adaptation is
solely needed in glasgow last year world
leaders vowed to scale back on the use
of fossil fuels but in fact the complete
opposite has happened emissions are
soaring as global demand for energy has
increased with economies bouncing back
from the effects of the pandemic
oil and gas prices have spiraled despite
promises banks are investing heavily
particularly in coal if we
move out of polluting fossil fuels such
as coal oil and gas and into clean
renewable energy sources such as wind
and solar we will cut emissions and
limit the global temperature rises and
as i said that gives chance for
adaptation measures to work
with the world rightly focused on the
crisis in ukraine this latest climate
report emphasizes global warming is a
fundamental long-term threat that cannot
be ignored
but the science shows it can be stopped
in its tracks if humanity cuts emissions
to zero
time though is running out
nick clark
al jazeera